andrés registras vehículos en el
departamento de transportes las
camionetas familiares son el 12 por
ciento de los vehículos que ella
registra sabe el número de vehículos que
andrea registra en un día hasta que
registra una camioneta familiar supón
que cada tipo de vehículo es
independiente encuentra la probabilidad
de que andreas registre más de 4
vehículos antes de registrar una
camioneta familiar pensemos en la
variable aleatoria de es el número de
vehículos que andrea registra en un día
hasta que registra una camioneta
familiar por ejemplo si la primera
persona que llega a registrar un
vehículo con andrea tiene una camioneta
familiar entonces ve será igual a 1 si
la primera persona no tiene una
camioneta familiar pero la segunda
persona si va a registrar una entonces
ve será igual a 2 y así sucesivamente
esta es una variable aleatoria
geométrica clásica tenemos un valor de
éxito bastante específico para cada
ejecución si se registra una camioneta
familiar o no nos dicen que cada
ejecución es independiente la
probabilidad de éxito en cada ejecución
es constante correspondiente al 12% del
total de las personas que llegan a
registrar un vehículo la razón por la
que esta no es una variable aleatoria
binomial es que no tenemos un número
determinado de ejecuciones seguiremos
realizando ejecuciones vamos a seguir
atendiendo a personas que lleguen a
registrar su vehículo hasta que alguien
llegue a registrar una camioneta
familiar lo que nos preguntan aquí es
cuál es la probabilidad de que d sea
mayor a 4 como siempre los invito a que
pause en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta
suponiendo que andreas no va a dejar su
escritorio hasta que alguien llegue a
registrar una camioneta familiar supongo
que ustedes ya intentaron resolver esto
por su cuenta así que vamos a
resolverlos juntos quizá algunos de
ustedes piensen que esto es igual a la
probabilidad de que d sea igual a 5 más
la probabilidad de que sea igual a 6 más
la probabilidad de que sea igual a 7 y
así sucesivamente esto es verdadero pero
cómo calculamos la suma de un número
infinito de términos aquí debemos darnos
cuenta de que la probable
de que sea mayor que 4 es lo mismo que
la probabilidad de que b no sea menor o
igual a 4 estas dos cosas son
equivalentes pero cuál es la
probabilidad de que b no sea menor o
igual a 4 seguramente es más sencillo el
calcular la probabilidad de que b no sea
menor o igual a 4 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de calcularlo a que es igual esto
es igual a la probabilidad de que los
primeros cuatro vehículos a registrar
no sean camionetas familiares esto es
bastante sencillo de calcular cuál es la
probabilidad de que el vehículo a
registrar no sea una camioneta familiar
es 1 - 12% que es 88% o 0.88 si queremos
la probabilidad de que los primeros
cuatro vehículos a registrar no sean
camionetas será a 0.88 a la cuarta
potencia sacamos la calculadora y
escribimos 0.88 elevado a la cuarta
potencia nos da esto que vamos a
redondear como 0.5 1997 lo escribimos si
quieren escribirlo como porcentaje sería
aproximadamente 59 punto 97 por ciento
un porcentaje mayor a la mitad y menor a
dos terceras partes para que andreas
registre una camioneta familiar después
de cuatro ejecuciones y con esto
terminamos